hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
from design to implementation of tsar's
kobe 2
diagnostic testing i am michelle ashton
of labrutz and i'll be your moderator
for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by labyrinth
and brought to you by abbott scientific
affairs molecular diagnostics
to learn more please visit the sponsored
by tab
let's get started before we begin i
would like to remind everyone that this
event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate
by submitting as many questions as you
want at any time you want during the
presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send questions will be
answered during the presentation
and also via email following this event
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation
click on the support tab found at the
top right of the presentation window
or report your problem by clicking on
the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
this presentation is educational and
thus offers
continuing education credits please
click
on the continuing education credits tab
located
at the top right of the presentation
window
and follow the process to obtain your
credits
i now present today's speakers dr gavin
clardy
head of infectious disease research at
abbott diagnostics
dr frederick multi professor and vice
chair
laboratory medicine and medical director
of clinical laboratories
and molecular pathology the medical
university
of south carolina and dr james kirby
the associate professor of pathology at
harvard medical school
and director of the clinical
microbiology laboratory
at beth israel's goodness medical for a
complete biography
on our speakers please visit the
biography tab
at the top of your screen our speakers
will now begin their presentations
it's a real pleasure to be here today
and to have the opportunity to present
you know the design and development
concepts and implementation of our sars
kobe 2 diagnostic tests and
you know to to share uh this
presentation with dr nolte is also a
great pleasure
um so you know when i was given this
title
of a talk i decided to take the
approach in developing the talk of just
putting you in the context of what we
were thinking
as this whole pandemic was unfolding
before us
and how we went about approaching the
diagnostic develop
the development of diagnostic tests real
quick let me walk through these
preliminary slides so the
mandatory disclaimer i'll leave that up
there for a second
and um obviously the the title of the
talk is uh the design and development of
soros kobe to
uh diagnostic assays um
the learning objectives for for this
talk
uh will be talking a little bit about
the sars
kobe 2 in disease and the virus
a little bit about the molecular assay
design and development and also the
serological i'm going to focus
on the core lab assays uh
which were more directly involved in and
not on the
um the rapid diagnostic point of care
tests that were more peripherally
involved in
the development of those guys so
we're going to review the challenges and
uh
again of the nucleic acid test
development and
serological test development as well as
talk a little bit about the
um what we're learning about this virus
as we go along so then to get into the
talk
in earnest we'll we'll start off by by
looking at the
sars kovi to virus and disease
associated with it
and if we look at this slide i think you
see um
in it in context so it's not the first
uh sars
uh kovi uh chronovirus that we've seen
obviously if we share this uh space with
the
normal uh beta corona viruses these the
four strains that cause the common cold
but
the the first stars that came around in
2003 i think it was
um uh it killed about 700 or 800 people
i think the numbers
very very slightly but the mortality was
about 9.5 percent if we look at
mers uh the mortality was significantly
higher at 35 percent
and now we see uh the thesaurus kobe 2
of mortality is about seven percent and
that
uh the exact numbers above that are kind
of changed
daily and this uh uh these numbers were
taken from the
end of april so obviously things have
changed since then i think it's um
interesting that that the uh initial
soros kovi
did burn itself out mers still kind of
percolates a little bit and pops up
every now and again
but uh this uh current um outbreak of
stars kobe 2 has really become a
pandemic
um so the difference um biology or
natural history of these viruses
are slightly different but what is
similar are the same
is the importance of the diagnostics so
the the importance of accurate and
timely diagnostics
um in in identifying cases
that enable a rapid reaction both
clinically and from the public health
space
is critical i think on the right hand
side of the slide you see a
quote from the eu commission
so this uh illustration just shows a
normal
you know kind of uh immunological
response and biological response to
to an infection with uh a normal virus
what you would expect and
this uh the reason for putting this
slide in here is to kind of
present you with what we were thinking
you know uh but we were very much
conscious of the fact that we didn't
know this was a new virus and we
couldn't make any assumptions but
if we had to make an assumption here's a
starting point
and this led us to focus
initially on the most urgent clinical
need which was the identification of
people who are actively
infected in that acute phase that would
need to be done with a molecular test
with a direct marker
uh so a molecular test for the viral rna
um later we can maybe in another talk we
can talk about antigen
but uh and then following on that we
knew that
the the most pressing uh question would
be who's recovered who might be
able to go back uh you know to work or
those kind of key questions that people
have
so we focused on the igg response next
but we
also didn't want to mask any information
again we'd want to be like
you know a term arrogant to think that
we would know everything about the
this virus so we can just lump all of
the serology together so
we separated out the igg and igm
development work streams
to make sure that we could have the most
granular information
about the patient in front of a
physician or the population
that a public health system was was
facing and so that will bear out and
you'll see a little bit more
about that in these slides that follow
so our thinking
um you know i think which is bearing out
uh was that if if you look at this slide
here it shows the different
uh molecular and serological markers and
what they might tell somebody so if
you've got a pcr positive on its own
it's most likely the early acute uh
phase where the body has not mounted an
immune response and
at least enough to be detected moving
into pcr
plus igm you're in that kind of middle
phase where normally pcr will start to
wane a little bit
and the igm will start to come up so you
usually within the first week of symptom
onset first week or two
but your igg is still negative you can
have that spot where
igm is the only marker that's positive
and this
this might be in the like the the um
within again the first week or so and
there may be a day difference or two is
what we're seeing between igm and igg
coming up positive
but that might be an important thing to
note because if you didn't do that igm
both would be uh negative and you might
miss that case
and actually there are cases when all
three are positive because we're finding
that igg
is very a very sensitive marker that
comes up uh quite early
and then there are other permutations
where pcr and igm can be
positive if you're in the late stage of
infection or maybe there's
a miss by the igm assay or just again
you get into
the later phases where serology is only
positive in
in the end igg is the most durable
marker
that would indicate for exposure and a
past infection
so this slide here which we i pulled
this graphic from
a very short review paper scissor
mounted island jama it was
online at may 6th and it's an
interesting one
um and sorry short paper so i'd
recommend it but what it shows
is how different this picture what's
important i think is how different this
picture
is when you compare it to what we
expected and or could have expected in
the previous slide
you you'll note that the the rna
detectability definitely differs in the
course of infection
uh and by the sample type you know
whether it's a nasopharyngeal
nasal or a throat sputum or whether it's
a stool sample
whether or not the p you'll be pcr
positive
depends on that sample type and also
when this sample is taken
um also surprising well maybe not so
surprising because we saw a similar
thing with sar with the original sars
infections that
igg and igm come up at almost the same
time
uh there may be a day or two difference
we'll we'll talk about that a little
later but igm
does drop off more uh quickly than the
igg which remains positive
and an important note is that this virus
has only been in the human population
for a couple of months so
that's about that's all we can tell is
how long these these markers last
is in that limited time period
uh here we look at um you know the some
of the potential
uses for diagnostics and where they
could
fit in so initially
for diagnosis of the most critical one
is the molecular test the pcr test which
is
you know the gold standard for
identifying those patients who are
ill and actively viremic an antigen test
may have application there that would
definitely depend on the format and the
sensitivity
and then antibody testing can have an
application
i we may have a slide on that later but
just in terms of if you're in that spot
where the pcr may be waning and the um
the the serology may be becoming
positive it may have
the ability to pick up some incremental
uh positives there
there's a use for diagnostics in
discharge and you know this is
actively in debate uh exactly what that
should look like um this current
european commission
uh guideline recommends an rna test so
negative consecutive
negative rna tests uh but you could also
complement that with serology so if
you're you're negative with your rna but
and you have let's say an igg response
um that might give you greater
confidence
particularly if it's a robust igg
response in in releasing somebody
and obviously for serological surveys
for epidemiology for understanding
who has been infected really the the the
main
marker for that would be serology and
igg particularly because it's the most
durable marker so
you can see who has been infected and
how that is changing in a pop at the
population level
over time
moving on to this slide i think what's
important you know we showed some slides
previously that
had been the normal virological response
what we're seeing in general with the
soros kobe 2 but this slide really
illustrates that it's a personal journey
and it will
from a serological perspective uh change
uh person to person
so you see four different subjects here
uh some of them
the the initial three are are more
normal
in subject one becomes positive after
you know
several days of symptoms uh subject to
would become positive after almost like
13 14 days
uh takes that person to become positive
subject three was positive
right from the initial time point at day
12.
but in the in subject four where you've
got an immunocomp an immune compromised
uh patient as a transplant patient they
did mount an immune response but it was
later
and i think this is something to keep in
mind when you see
negative results let's say 14 days after
uh
symptom onset or more you really have to
look
at what's going on with that that
individual
and it's no i think in a specific test
is the silver bullet you've got to look
at the entire um
all the information you can and the
clinical picture in front of you to make
a diagnosis and understand what's going
on
on the right hand panel here was pulled
from a from a paper
um i think it was tanadal but what they
looked at was uh the different
uh the different response in patients
who were critically ill and that was
defined as being on a
respirator or you know not critically
ill so they would have been
not on a respirator that would but would
vary from ambulatory
on up but what it showed was that the
the igg response was significantly
stronger in those patients who were
critically ill from those who were not
i think you know more information will
need to to
is coming out on the significance of
that kind of robust response versus not
i think
what we may be seeing is two different
kind of diseases one
is more biologically mediated and
another could be
immunologically mediated so you know uh
depending on what the immune system is
actually doing to the body in a given
in a given patient more on that
now to talk about the design and
development of the different assets that
we were
that we we worked on and kind of put you
in the mind frame
you know the space that we were in is
what i'll attempt to do here
and this slide um just speaks to the
different things you've got to do
normally when you're developing an assay
and i think many people on
the the call today will be familiar with
that you know the bioinformatics the
initial asset design
sample prep optimization the kind of
evaluation validation that iterative
cycles that go on
and just for reference when we're
normally building a test
for fda submission and the normal ce
mark this
takes years years of iterative process
and hard work to get this done
and to put things in context this slide
shows
how we accomplish this in weeks so
initially in the ide core where we sit
at abbott we were monitoring what was
going on in china and looking at
how things were developing uh with great
interest and concern
um the main thing we needed was a
sequence i think uh you know
this this was noted previously you know
we really
that is the starting point for building
a molecular test so i think it was
january 20th if memory serves me
and you have to forgive me because you
know with everything being so contents
there's a slight fog
on the exact dates but i believe it was
uh january 20th
when the sequence became publicly
available and that was the day that we
um hit go and started building designing
the primers and probes
and getting those ordered for synthesis
and that takes a bit of time so we had a
little lag
until we had all of the oligos and uh in
vitro transcripts and everything in
place
that was around february 14th so that
really was when things started in the
the wet lab development in earnest and
we had a prototype essay
available uh within days um
which actually you know i the the point
i make on
march 5th there was we developed this
with a certain enzyme formulation and
then we realized you know this would
need to be done
on scale and you know the and it really
hit us how much scale that would be
needed and how fast this would need to
be done
so we reformulated uh with a different
enzyme to accommodate this kind of
manufacturing i want to
tip my house at this point to the guys
in manufacturing who've really
you know had to step up to meet the
demand
uh and and do it in in really quick time
as well
so we did that reformulation and got
ready uh for eua verification studies by
march 14th and then
eua submission and again tip my hat to
to the fda
uh for making this channel open and for
working so quickly to get this done
in like a 24 hour period for turnaround
and then getting this launched
so this was a whirlwind as you can
imagine uh
also you know wanted to draw note the
fact that we were developing an asean
really really limited sequence data
we had uh you know one two maybe three
as the days progressed
sequences so we were i don't want to say
flying by the seat of our pants but
because we
know what we're doing but it was
definitely a lot of sleepless nights as
this was going because things could have
gone sideways at any time
we tried our best to uh mitigate
all of this risk um by selecting
targets uh we took a dual target
approach um you know that really is kind
of getting to be the the gold standard
in pcr we wanted to build in some
redundancy in case we saw some
mismatches
we targeted um nuclear capsid and rdrp
because uh we found that that is the
most highly conserved stretches is where
we found so
in addition to looking at the region
like nuclear capsid or
drp you can throw those terms out it's
really more important to look at the
sequence within those
and um as we have the global
surveillance program ongoing for
you know many decades and this is our
stock in trade
we really dug into those sequences to
find the ones where we
thought would be the best targets boats
from uh conservation
now but into the future as much of a
crystal ball as we could try and and
work to predict
um so both of these targets co-amplify
in the test that was the design and also
to include the normal
armored pumpkin gene internal control as
we have in all our reti real-time assays
into this for additional um
additional quality control
so this slider um we look at the target
selection that we had
versus some of the others that were kind
of out around the same coming out around
the same time
and um we see that we were in rdrp
so is was charity in berlin
as was the cdc and we also had a target
in n
uh but i think more importantly than
just saying we were in n
and rdrp it's where we were uh in these
c
in these uh regions is the critical uh
part then needed to prove uh they are
past the test of time
we also looked at e and we have that as
a target region we can swap in or out if
we needed to but there was no
incremental benefit to that
so moving forward you know we didn't
just rest on those initial couple of
sequences
as you can imagine we were keenly
watching how this space was
evolving looking specifically at the
target regions where we were and this
slide shows some analysis that was done
using genbank sequences looking for the
primary programmology
looking at 13 more than 1300 full-length
genomes
and we found that 99.5 had a 100
identity
it was 99.5 of the sequences had 100
percent
identity to our primers and probes there
were
a few as you always would expect there
will be that had some mismatches there
was a single mismatch
um in in uh six uh of the
uh samples uh to our end target and one
to rdrp uh there was no single
sample that had mismatches to
both the targets and none that would
have any impact
on the assay performance again looking
at
more sequence i think this time from the
gisa id database
looking at almost 15 000 samples
again we found 1.1 percent contained a
single mismatch this won't impact the
test
um 0.4 had two and .007 so one out of
the
almost fifteen thousand had four
mismatches
uh all in one of the gene sequences and
um
so the this none of these um mismatches
or profiles
would impact the performance of the test
and
that is definitely very reassuring but
now that this uh virus is
is with us it is part of our global
surveillance program so we are actively
looking
around the world in in many many many
different countries
and uh generating sequence and looking
at the homology to our primers and
probes and the
performance of our tests so this is
firmly part of our global surveillance
program and our reality moving forward
and looking at some of the performance
data broadly that that
has been done with this test it's very
gratifying to see that the clinical
correlation
across all sites is greater than 95
percent and we haven't seen any
cross-reactivity
and uh we've confirmed that 100 copies
per ml
or greater um and by that probably means
less so
you know it could be 100 copies or less
as the limit of detection um
so we we've we've seen some like in the
university of washington where we've got
93 percent
uh pick up at 25 copies um
so that's uh very reassuring i think if
we look at
the other sites here we're seeing a
limited detection of 100 copies being
reported
with almost 100 percent positive and
negative agreement
to the cdc assay
and the luminex assay you know the cdc
we have 100
positive negative agreement and then
with the luminex assay there was
uh one sample where there was a uh not
uh
a difference in the negative agreement
so that's um
that's extremely reassuring uh both for
us in our test but also for the field
who if you're using the cdc or one of
these other tests i think it's
very valuable information
again looking at the the platforms you
know we we developed this test for the
m2000
which is the old uh i would say over the
workhorse
that's around the world uh many
thousands of placements
but also this test was ported over onto
the elenady m
which is the i guess new
state-of-the-art platform you'd call it
um which has significant
uh benefits in terms of throughput uh
you know with about a thousand tests per
day
uh so that's that's it's a fantastic uh
piece of equipment
um so we reported that test over onto
this platform
if you see here um the data looking at
the positive and negative agreement
um you'll see uh 47 uh
positive samples were also put with
m2000 were positive with the alinity
and there were two samples that were
negative with the m2000 that were
uh positive with the limit em and these
one these samples had a
cycle number of about 40 almost 40
pretty much 41.
so that's at the very low end of the
dynamic range so we did see
a couple of incremental pickups with
eliminating so the positive
agreement was 100 and the negative
predictive value was
96.5 so again uh
quite uh comfortable with that with that
data
so in closing slide you know what's next
i think
uh you know it's important to know does
uh how much uh
virus is present in a person is that
important so
rna quantitation could be significant if
rna is present in the blood
and how much could be an important um uh
question to answer
if we link that to clinical progress or
you know the clinical picture
from the serology perspective the key
question does antibody positivity equal
immunity
does the how much antibodies present
does that influence immunity or disease
progression
clinical outcomes when vaccines are
developed
i think it's important uh that could be
quantitation could become
extremely important if we look at
hepatitis and other vaccines where
you know we need to know if the vaccine
has elicited a response that would
confer immunity or not
therapeutic interventions whether they
be monoclonals or other
what impact will that have on the
diagnostic test what role will the
diagnostic
tests play both in the development and
the utility of those
those therapeutic interventions and then
the ongoing epidemiology whether it be
surveys or surveillance
i think it's critically important and on
the right hand of this picture i think
it shows
i like it because it illustrates kind of
where we're coming from where we were
where we are where we're going to
you know from the reactive clinical
management um
you know at the outset of this pandemic
you know under
and that's still extremely important as
we still have people coming in who are
infected today
but expanding out to look at the
population level
looking for hot spots seeing how that's
changing uh you know
allocation of resources how will
diagnostics and the ability to
understand what this virus is doing as
the pandemic
evolves you know under and being able to
answer these questions and look at
things critically
i think will be important moving forward
so with that
i think that's the end of my talk i want
to thank again
for the opportunity to talk to you today
and present i'm very happy
to have been here and i hope this was an
informative talk for you
i just want to take a moment to thank uh
abbott molecular for asking me to
participate in this webinar my name is
frederic nolte
i'm at the medical university of south
carolina i'm vice chair for pathology
and laboratory medicine
and medical director for clinical labs
and what i'd like to share with
you folks today is our clinical
laboratory response to the covid19
pandemic and we'll go through
the standard disclaimers i won't read
these and the audience knows that
the support for this program is provided
by abbott i am presenting at the request
of abbott
and you can see all the disclaimers
regarding the use of the
uh the tests that i'm going to be
talking about from abbott
what i plan to do in the next 25 minutes
or so
are review the particular challenges and
successes
that we have had in responding to the
increasing demand for diagnostic testing
for sars
ob2 um we're going to i'm going to spend
most of my time talking about nucleic
acid amplification test for
detection of viral rna i do have one
slide at the end that touches on our
serological testing for the detection of
antibodies we have a
orthogonal algorithm that i think may be
of interest to the audience
and i've spent a lot of time describing
our experience with the abbott m2000
uh sars coronavirus ii eua assay
and if you'll just permit me a moment to
share a personal reflection
um yeah this is deja vu all over again
for me this is a publication that we put
out
and put it together in 2003
but it is in response to the first sars
outbreak and you all remember that
in november of 2002 there was an
outbreak of atypical pneumonia
with a high fatality rate that emerged
in guadalang province and china
that became known as uh severe acute
respiratory syndrome
and the virus became known as the tsar's
coronavirus
it quickly spread to five continents and
by the time it burned itself
out in 2003
uh wh estimated there were 8400 cases
and approximately 812
deaths so um why is this this relevant
this publication well
um at the time we didn't know what um
what the furosaurs outbreak was going to
look like
the u.s was largely largely spared
any big impact with that but we were in
a situation where
i first time in in my professional
career when a new virus emerged
immediately genomic information was
available and shared
molecular amplification assays detect
the virus were there
and we had no idea what the future
it was going to look like when it came
to sars
so we took it on ourselves to develop
and validate two laboratory developed
tests
we put them through their paces we we
had access to the appropriate reference
material
both commercial and from investigators
around the world
we were able to contrive samples uh we
were able to do the
the clinical validation piece the
analytical validation piece
and we did it very quickly and i want to
just keep this
in mind that this is in uh 2002
it's now 2020 and some of the challenges
that we
are facing now in response to the second
sars coronavirus uh
problem um weren't there in the early
2000s
so keep that in mind and also
i'm kicking myself a little bit i had
the foresight
in 2002 to be prepared before
the emergency or before we knew this
was going to be a public health threat i
was a little behind the curve
for this one the current one as were
many other laboratories
so what i'm going to do is try to tell a
story with the next few slides and take
you through the
you know one lab's experience the
evolution of molecular testing
capacities for sars covid ii here at
the medical university of south carolina
so early in the pandemic all testing for
persons under investigation was
conducted at our public health
and cdc laboratories and it was all
coordinated through our local
um uh epidemiologists that were
tasked here from the state health lab in
columbia
so as you might imagine the surge
capacity of the public health lab
and the cdc for testing was quickly
exceeded
our initial plan here at musc was to
offer
the only eua available at the time
uh the cdc test this is our first
issue with supply chain we purchased the
reagents the required instruments we got
the right
reference material to validate but we
couldn't get
the needed instrument to perform the
test the
abi 7500 fast ex we didn't have one
available in our laboratory
um we placed an order um the
we learned that the uh the instruments
are shipped from china
and so the boat was on the uh since the
instrument was on the slow boat
from china and took um uh
several months took two months to arrive
uh we also realized while we were
waiting for it and with the increasing
demand that the
cdc assay really wasn't going to provide
us with the testing capacity
that we needed to support the demand
so our activities really ramped up here
around mid-march the 13th of march
musc has tremendous capabilities in the
telehealth arena
and we leverage that capability and
expertise to facilitate
evaluation and scheduling of local
patients and healthcare workers
were testing at a remote specimen
collection site
we made the decision that we didn't want
to bring these patients into the
emergency room or the
or the clinic because of the the risk of
transmission
in those environments so the testing
capacity
uh at the time we opened this of the
large national referral laboratories was
stressed with long turnaround times for
results
we had no local testing capacity because
we were waiting uh for the delivery of
the
the abi instrument from china so we were
forced
to use a regional commercial laboratory
for testing to support that
collection site but unfortunately they
lack the experience and capacity
to deal with the demand in a timely
fashion
so here's where the story gets
interesting
with respect to abbott so shortly after
we opened the
our first collection remote collection
site
i was approached by abbott scientific
affairs asking me if i was interested
in taking a look at their eua
assay on the m2000
i responded very quickly and i said yes
um there's a number of reasons why it
was a great
fit for us uh we have been um
an abbot m2000 user for over a decade we
had two instruments in our in our
laboratory
um abbott offered to to um
supply us with a third m2000
uh we the the speed by which we
got everything done was unprecedented
basically in just over a week
we went from having the reagents to
to having the test validating and
bringing it online
so we started collecting specimens from
patients in an organized fashion
on the 13th of march and we were live
with the abbott m2000
on the 23rd uh this obviously we went
from
zero uh to about a thousand tests per
day capacity uh in a matter of a couple
of weeks
um we say our our turnaround time is in
the 24 to 48 hour window
um but our in reality the average
turnaround time for specimen receipt to
result
at um is typically 12 hours for us
our initial attempts to dilute genomic
rna in universal transport media and
viral transport media resulted in poor
and inconsistent recovery
which was a bit of a surprise to me but
i guess i shouldn't have been surprised
by that
however the same dilutions of the jomek
rna made in saline
showed excellent recovery down to as low
as 10 copies per mil
in our initial range finding experiments
for the
limit of detection this shows that the
data for that dilution series and
the crossing uh numbers uh done in
in the quadruplicate and the mean
crossing numbers so the coefficient of
variation of the
crossing numbers are range from 1.3 to
4.7
depending upon the concentration
so the next step uh was to look at some
of the other commercially
or or the commercially available
material that was
there for us we used the exact
diagnostics and the zero care reference
material both of which have been
quantified by
digital uh droplet pcr
this just shows you that they all worked
in the in the m2000 assay it gives you
the
expected concentrations and the cycle
the crossing numbers for those
materials uh to confirm them uh
abbott's uh limited detection claim of
100 copies per mill we diluted one of
the serial killer
panel members and tested it 20 times at
a
nominal concentration of 100 copies per
mil all 20 were
uh were detected with an average
crossing number of 26.7
the clinical verification of the assay
started out with the residual clinical
specimens that were collected
during the early phases of our
opening of a remote collection site so
they were
collected from march 12 through 17.
all of the specimens were sent to a
regional commercial reference lab for
testing by the cdc eua assay
we tested the specimens locally with the
biofire respiratory panel as well
we were also able to acquire 10 uh
positive specimens from our
local public health laboratory that had
been tested by the cdc essay
and then we had finally received our
instrument
our fast ex instrument and since we had
all of the reagents on hand we
did a local lab comparison if you will
of the cdc eua assay performed
at musc uh with the abbott result so we
did that with 12 positive and 12
negative
specimens so that can um that comprises
a clinical verification data set or
specimens um so
we took 183 residual np samples so
we've been through these two points so
the problem is when we looked at
our agreement with the
regional referral laboratory it was less
than ideal
the positive present agreement was only
75 percent there are a small number of
positive specimens in this mix um
the the n1 n2
cycle thresholds in the cdc cdc test
were for the false negatives are listed
here and they're in the 30s
uh low 30s to high 30s i'm not sure what
to to make of that
the referral laboratory also reported
three inconclusive specimens
that they were unable to reproduce the
results
they tested negative by abbott so faced
with this
[Music]
we wanted to do a better job of looking
at the how well the abbott
assay compared to the cdc eu assay so
the 12 specimens that we received from
our local public health lab they were
randomly selected
and they the positive and negative
predictive values were
100
we did so looking
at the i'm sorry the the second bullet
point or the locally performed
test uh the first bullet point or what
we got from the public health lab in
both cases the positive predictive
agreement was 100
so overall if you put all three data
sets together we found a 91 percent
uh positive predictive agreement and 100
negative predictive agreement between
the results of the cdc
and the abbott test and but we did see
there with the positive predictive
agreement was
dependent uh upon where the test was
performed so
there is some interlaboratory variation
in in that in terms of the
how the results compare
to the eu to the cdc eua essay
um the clinical verification also
included comparison
uh to the the um
respiratory virus panel results from
biofire
uh there were 168 specimens that were
concordant
negative for for covid uh for asarius
coronavirus 2 rna
we found other respiratory pathogens in
71 of those or 42 percent
and i'm not going to read all of the
different viruses we recovered but the
important thing is highlighted there
they were in this data set there were 18
uh specimens that were positive for
seasonal coronaviruses
uh which was actually um quite
interesting because that's more
um positives than we had for for uh
sars coronavirus two in this uh data set
and from this it allowed us to to you
know pretty robustly say that the abbett
assay was free of cross-reaction with
seasonal
coronaviruses as well as the other
common respiratory
pathogens so that's basically what we
did for the initial
analytical and clinical verification of
the
assay on the m2000 so this is kind of
the
the end of the the m2000 story and where
we are
today not that we're through with the
m2000s but this is
uh where the m2000s have gotten us to
date
so um since we went live on the 23rd of
march
we have performed almost 44 000 tests
from individuals throughout south
carolina and identified 2 000 patients
our current positivity rate taking all
comers is is at 4.36 percent
you can see in the panel over here the
steady growth in positive patients per
day
the test positivity since we're serving
this heat map over here
shows the um the different locations
that we are serving
and the number of positive patients in
those zip codes
if you will and the darker red indicates
the higher
uh percent positive and that percent
positivity rate from the patient
populations we serve ranges from a low
of 2.85 percent
up to a high of almost 11
we are the second leading provider of
testing uh behind labcorp
in the state of south carolina we're
quite proud of that
ah finally yes uh light at the end of
the tunnel
um the ability um
we are an early we have one of the early
instruments
uh it's been with us for a couple of
weeks now it's finally we're finally at
a point where we are able to start
the validation process i'm going to
share that
limited data with you in just a moment
but the reason that we're so excited
about it is it's basically the same
assay
that we've been running for the past
four months on the m2000
but the design of the instrument and the
way
the functionality and the throughput
is phenomenal so basically we expect to
get as many results out of a single
uh linear dm instrument as we do out of
all three of our m2000s
the analysis time is much shorter the
random access
and the stun stat functionality will
help us with those demands for urgent
results
there are a lot of other good things
about it
but it it really is we're really quite
pleased to have it and hope to go live
with it
this friday actually as soon as we get
some of the i.t
issues squared away uh just
again this data i'm going to share with
you is very preliminary it's
it's the basis of of two of our
verification runs that were done just a
couple of days ago
uh the first was to document the the
limit of detection
again using the accuplex uh verification
panel
as a source of material uh we diluted
that down to the
following the nominal com concentrations
from 25 to
400 copies per mill you can see at the
100 copy per ml which is a stated limit
of detection
uh we hit that 95 percent mark
we feel that we can probably push that
down to 250
copies per mil based on this sort of
rangefinding
experiment so we're going to give that a
try on a subsequent
verification run and here is the
comparison of clinical specimens run on
the
the two instruments we have the avid
m2000 and the alinity m results we had
109 frozen
np swaps that were previously tested on
the m2000 we retested them on alinity
we found a positive predictive agreement
of 90
and a negative predictive agreement of
98 percent
we are currently investigating uh
a little deeper those samples that were
reported positive on
alinity i'm sorry on m2000 but negative
on the alinity m uh you can see that the
uh
the site the crossing numbers there for
those specimens range for were
on the high side but not extremely high
27.8 to 31.4 and we did have one sample
that tested positive
on the alinity m that was negative by
abbott
on the m2000 uh with a very uh
high crossing number of 40.99
so i know that was a lot um but i'm
going to leave you with
several final thoughts uh clinical
laboratory professionals are in the
vanguard of the response to the sars
pandemic providing accurate high quality
laboratory results aid in the diagnosis
treatment
and epidemiology
in this role we have encountered a new
number of regulatory reimbursement
supply chain logistical and systems
problems
that we have struggled to overcome in
order to fulfill our calling to provide
patient care
we are thankful for reliable industry
partners in this process
and i can't say enough about habit and
and
how they have supported our efforts
hopefully
our collective experience will be i mean
our experience like here at musc will be
of value to others
dealing with similar uh challenges and
the lessons we learn as a
community uh will make us better able to
deal with the next
pandemic thank you for your attention
hi my name is james kirby i'm the
medical director of clinical
microbiology at beth israel deaconess
medical center
and i wanted to share with you some
insights from
uh that we've obtained from sars kobe 2
testing
using the abbott m2000 and alinity
molecular diagnostic platforms this
speaker program
is sponsored by abbott and the
presentation will be
consistent with all applicable fda
requirements
so just uh this slide is a reminder of
emergency use authorization and what
that means
so i'll start out with our studies with
the
avid m2000 real time sars kobe 2
assay so that assay is a qualitative
emergency use authorization assay that
generates either positive or negative uh
results but sort of under the hood it
also provides
results which can be used to understand
quantitative performance of the assays
because
real time pcr assays as you know are
inherently quantitative
and during each amplification
cycle uh essentially to some
approximation um the number of uh
amplicons is doubled and um
there's simultaneous amplification and
binding of a probe and that probe
fluorescent
signal therefore increases uh
geometrically during each amplification
cycle
and at some point the
um the signal from that fluorescence
crosses
a threshold and at least in some
systems we call that threshold the cycle
threshold so it's the
amplification cycle number at which that
threshold for detection is reached and
the abbott systems
uh use a slightly different
thresholding measurement it's called the
fractional cycle number
or just cn or cycle number for short but
i'll
refer to that as a cycle threshold or
use those terms interchangeably the
the generation of the fractional cycle
numbers are actually very interesting
um and i'll refer to you
i'll refer you to the study by shane and
clements if you're interested in
more details about how that number is
determined
but um it is it's a way to
um uh sort of avoid some of the uh
artifacts and uh fluorescent of
baselining okay but we don't need to
know those uh details
just that we get this very important uh
cycle number information
the m2000 assay and the
uh alinity assay that i'll tell you
about later
they're both dual target assays so
they're detecting two targets within the
sars
cov2 virus and
importantly the assays have a robust
limit of detection
and so um as i mentioned
um real-time pcr is inherently
quantitative and so you know
our uh goal was then to be able to take
this
cycle threshold values and convert that
into a viral load
and see what that could tell us about
our testing results and our patient
population
so we determined that our limit of
detection
was um a hundred copies per
penum copies per mill um in
across our four different avid m2000
analyzers and the ct value was
approximately 26
and um you know as i mentioned uh
with pcr amplification if it's a 100
efficient you know that each cycle
number you're going to double
the number of amplicons so you go from 2
4 8 16
32 64 etc so
you can approximate the viral load so we
know
that for example that 100 is our lod
so you can use this sort of simple
formula 100 times
2 raised to the
limit of the ct at the limit of
detection minus
the ct for any given assay
to come up with an approximate borrower
load so
and that sort of makes sense because if
your ct was 25
that means you're basically one
your resulting one
cycle earlier so you would expect that
your viral load would be twice as high
as your limit of detection
if you if you plug that into the formula
you get a viral load of 200
if you're one cycle later then you're
limited detection
you plug it into the formula you get a a
bar load of 50.
well of course nothing in life is that
simple because
amplification efficiency is less than
100
and it decreases with cycle number and
you could these are graphs
of two positive samples
one with a very low ct and
one on the right with very high ct
near the limit of detection and you can
see that there's more
sort of the slope is steeper
with a a sample with a very high viral
load that gets detected
earlier and as you go through
additional amplification signals to
reach your
threshold the amplification becomes less
efficient
by basically looking at
a lot of different curves like this
we're able to empirically establish a
formula
which we think fairly accurately
predicts the viral load
and from this from the ct value and
we've
sort of published
some of this data now in bio
archive if you're interested in more
detail so
i'll just leave it that we think that we
have a pretty good approximation of
viral load
and so then we looked at
our uh data from march 26 to may
2nd and you know that was sort of our
big surge
in the state of massachusetts so we did
27 000
tests we had 6 000 positives 4 700
unique patients
and so we had two questions so for
a viral load to mean something one of
the questions was
well is it repeatable if you swab
someone's
nose and you get in twice in a row
and you've got a bar load of 100 one
time and 100 billion a second
then fire loads would not be clinically
useful because we wouldn't really they
wouldn't necessarily mean anything
and the second question was can we learn
anything from the viral load
distribution and
would that help us understand how to use
our testing
so in fact the ct values and therefore
the viral loads
are reproducible between nasopharyngeal
swabs collected across
short time intervals so in our very
large data set we had a bunch of
patients
who had repeat collections either within
six hours or within 12 hours of each
other we don't know the reasons why
and then we plotted the ct value from
the first collection
versus the ct value of the second
collection you can see
that we have a nice sort of linear
relationship throughout the range of ct
values that we
um would obtain so it looks uh like
um uh those ct values are
repeatable in a clinical sense if you
sample patients
uh more than once so they're telling us
truly
about um status
of our patients
okay so then we um
decided to basically we converted our ct
values
for patient first positives and
we that's about 4 700 patients and
we basically binned those
[Music]
those viral load results and
to show the fraction of cases in each
one half log 10 bin and so
our var loads range from very low up to
a billion
copies genome copies per ml and one of
the fascinating things was
that the distribution was fairly even
and so you see basically about the same
number a fraction of cases are
distributed
throughout the range of detection except
for
you know a drop off below 100 copies
per ml which is the limit of detection
so we
um considered that that was reflective
of the limit of detection of the assay
rather than
an actual uh change in distribution
so why this occurred occurs biologically
is
not clear and it perhaps is hand waving
but
it may reflect the fact that viruses
replicating logarithmically somehow with
burst
sizes that spread out and infect
large numbers of cells sort of
consecutively
but in either case what that sort of
allowed us to do was then
plot sort of a cumulative
distribution so essentially what we're
plotting here
is at every point on the x-axis
is sort of the fraction of cases that
would be caught above
a certain viral load so
for example approximately 80 percent
of the results that we would expect
would be caught with a viral load um
above uh 10 to the second genome copies
per ml
and so based upon sort of these results
what we what we did is we sort of
extrapolated with a red dotted line to
say
if we could detect consistently
basically a single virus
in um a reaction
what would that be and um
you know if if we made that
extrapolation and considered that
you know ideal detection of a hundred
percent
then that abbott assay would detect
about
90 percent of those patients so
the what i think is very important to
consider is if you sort of look
on the x-axis and then consider
the uh reported lods of different assays
so for
example the cdc assay has a limit of
detection of
a thousand or three thousand uh
depending upon the format that's
used the genmark eua has a little bit of
detection of
a thousand as reported in the literature
labcorp about
six thousand in the sofia antigen test
above uh a million um
if you sort of uh do convert the units
they
use based upon their reference material
um
that they use for their calibration into
uh genome copies per ml
so um you know these where you place
uh these numbers um there's probably
some
uh play but i think the important point
is that as you
increase your limit of detection
you significantly affect the fraction of
cases that you detect
so for example with the sophia antigen
test
you might expect that you would miss
more than 50 percent
of the cases that you might detect with
the
sort of best-in-class pcr
methods one of the things that i should
mention and one of the problems in the
field and again this is
early and we're in a crisis situation is
there's no
standard uh there's sort of no reference
standard
and a lot of these for benchmarking your
assay so the limit of detection
um and these uh uh a reported limit of
detections have been
um uh uh determined using different
reference materials
so um you know i i would say that
you know take this graph as an
approximation
and there's clearly a case for some
universal standard
for benchmarking so that we as a
clinical community
can really understand the differences
between these assays
okay when all this happened it was a
chance to review sort of the anatomy of
the
nasal passages we have nasopharyngeal
swabs which
proceed backwards into the you know
basically all the way back
um uh to the uh
nasopharynx and in red um we have nasal
swabs that
uh that sample more interiorly
and importantly the anterior nasal
passages uh
are lined with squamous epithelium the
virus
replicates in ciliated respiratory
epithelium so there's
some theoretical concern that anterior
nasal swabs may not necessarily
sample the right place so we know that
nasopharyngeal swabs appear to have the
best sensitivity
and they clearly sample respiratory
epithelium
however they're difficult to collect you
need
trained collection staff and they're
uncomfortable we don't have people that
want to come back and volunteer
for a testing unless under duress
nasal swabs are easy to collect however
they may not fully sample the
respiratory epithelium
depending upon their depth and
there's difference in the literature
regarding performance of nasal swaps
so we
performed a multi-arm
clinical trial to compare the
performance of nasopharyngeal swabs
to nasal swabs in our patient population
and we basically shown in this graph or
the ct values
the nasal swab and the ct values of the
nasopharyngeal swab
and anything that
which was negative we're reporting out
as a ct value in this graph of
37 and so you can see
that for um nasopharyngeal swabs with
ct values starting at about 21 and
especially going higher that we're
missing a lot of nasal swabs
and if we sort of plot this out
and this is a graph showing concordance
using a kappa statistic between
nasopharyngeal swabs and nasal swabs
these are done in parallel at the same
time in each patient
in that you know above
a thousand genome copies per ml there's
very good concordance but it rapidly
drops off
below a thousand copies per mil
so where does that leave us
and what's the use of nasopharyngeal
swabs
well first what's the explanation for
these observed differences
it's unclear it may be that
if you have a very exuberant infection
it spreads out more in the nasal
respiratory epithelium so it's easier
for
it to be sampled by nasal swabs but
that's
really unknown you know one question is
what makes a patient infectious and i
think that's what we're still trying to
understand
if you look in tissue culture and just
take for example the
bei resources cell culture control
material that many of us have been using
the ratio of genome copies to
the tissue culture infective dose
or 50 infective dose is about 10 000 to
1.
so you have to have you know a lot of
genome copies to get
a single uh infected tissue culture cell
and this is similar to what's been
observed in patients
so for example in the study by wolfel it
all
suggests that the ability to culture
any virus from patients appears to occur
with viral loads greater than a hundred
thousand during the coven 19
recovery phase so
what we think is that we should use the
most sensitive possible
collection technique nasopharyngeal
swabs in symptomatic patients
in patients who are being admitted to
hospitals and for contact raising
but the nasal swab in terms of
trade-offs
may be an excellent thing to use in
larger screening
campaigns and asymptomatic uh
individuals and
locally we've been having a lot of
discussion about
for example weekly sampling in oncology
campuses and potentially in businesses
and the nasal swab would provide an easy
sampling technique it would identify
patients who are infectious
and could then sort of reflex to further
contact tracing with
um or resampling
in those in let's say a dorm room that's
infected with
a targeted nasopharyngeal swab
testing in the arms of our study we
compared dry swabs which were sent to
the lab and anterior nasal swabs and
deep nasal swabs
and they appeared to perform
equivalently giving us
multiple options okay so i've told you
about studies with the m2000
platform shown on the left hand side of
the screen
we're very excited to be one of the
first
uh adopters in the united states of the
alinity
m platform so
we wanted to get a feeling for how the
assay performed against the m2000
so shown here about 50 positive samples
comparing cycle numbers for the m2000
and the elite and they were highly
correlated and r squared or 0.2
we see two samples which had a
lower uh cycle number for the validity
compared to the
sort of falling below that straight line
and
uh perhaps they were the amplification
in those samples were
um a little less less efficient on the
m2000
there was a shift in cycle number so
that
the cycle number for any given validity
uh assay was about 12 uh 12
ct or cn units higher that
you know raises no practical differences
and the assays were highly correlated
we also did a limited detection study
including testing at levels below the
claimed
limit of detection and using logistic
regression um we estimate the limit of
detection is about
45 you know we didn't do a huge number
of replicates so
the black dotted lines to the
left and right of the red dotted line
are the 95
confidence intervals so a limit of
detection was excellent
um and just as one final note
of the utility to be of being able to
access
uh the cycle number or cycle threshold
values
were able to use those to support
a number of different uh initiatives um
in our covert response
and i i'm sure that many of you um
like we like us had
issues acquiring
certain basically supplies
needed for sampling patients so we were
went into high production to make viral
transport media
uh we made about uh three to four
thousand
of our transport media tubes a day for
quite a long
uh period and what we would do is we
would for quality control
since we had many many uh batches that
we prepared
every time we had a new sort of block
we would spike a sample of that lot
at 2x the limit of detection with the
serocarry agent and determine the ct
value
and so these this is a plot of ct values
for different lots over a 30-day period
and so that's a levy jennings plot and
it's expected
since we're 2x lod for the avid m2000
assay we had a ct
mean of 25 and you know there was
pretty um uh uh uh tight
um uh amplification
uh showing us that you know each lot
there wasn't
um some sort of inhibitor that was
introduced and so that we could
you know use those for patient testing
and
um you know so that data has been
published
and um the first reference at the bottom
of the
bottom of the figure and then
we also worked with a number of
manufacturers
to help vet their 3d
printed swabs and one of the
questions that we had collectively
was whether they were using different
types of material to print their swabs
and
it was really important to know whether
anything would leach
into a viral transport media and cause
pcr inhibition
so we would soak the swabs and buy our
transport media overnight and then spike
the viral transport media 2x limited
detection
in um again look at ct values so we're
able to establish
whether uh there were inhibitors that
would affect
our uh testing so that was extremely
helpful
so in conclusion no viral load matters
especially the limit of detection of
your assays you really know
need to know what they are um and
that will impact the percentage of
patients that you will detect
i think there's a good uh case for a
universal standard that will allow
us to understand how different assays
uh compare um and you know
uh it's hard for one site to uh bring in
all the assays and compare them with the
same
material so a reference standard would
be really helpful
there's i think clearly role for both
nasal and nasopharyngeal swabs depending
upon the sensitivity
needed and i think nasal swabs will you
know find their use in supporting
screening of asymptomatic patients
the um abbott assays had robust
reproducibility
which supported quality control and
quality assurance
initiatives in our response and the
sample to answer a linear em platform
uh shows a low limit of detection
and a high degree of uh agreement with
m2000
and it's we can already see that sort of
sample to answer
and rapid turnaround uh
time has been very helpful in our
helping our hospital system i'd like to
acknowledge
a lot of people um annie chang our
molecular supervisor
tammy galloway our molecular laboratory
manager
we have an amazing group of clinical
laboratory
scientists and a lot of
volunteers from our research division
and elsewhere that have been keeping our
clinical lab and
pre-analytics and post analytics going
so i can't thank them enough
uh rami are now in the uh cls6
covid research team that have helped
with a lot of the studies that i
i told you about uh stefan riedel
associate micro director ryan pena
um uh the molecular uh clia
holder and um hla director in our
hospital system
our pathology administration and avid
molecular
and with that i will close and i'm happy
to answer any questions
thank you so much thank you all for your
informative presentations
we would also like to thank lavrov and
our sponsor abbott scientific affairs
molecular diagnostics
for underwriting today's educational
webcast
before we go i'd like to thank the
audience for joining us today and for
their interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period will be addressed by our speakers
via the contact information
you provided at the time of registration
lab routes will alert you via email when
this webinar is available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye